‘Atonement’ is a slightly unfamiliar,
old-fashioned and alien word. It means, according
to the dictionary, the action of making amends
for a wrong or injury and, especially in religious
contexts, reparation or expiation for sin.
The modern world chiefly believes that the
rightful way to amend for a wrong is either
to pay a fine or go to prison. These are,
in certain circumstances, surely the best
moves – but they fail to deal with what
is in the end the far largest category of
wrongs that humans commit: instances of everyday
nastiness, error, foolishness, lack of empathy
and shortsightedness. Fining or imprisoning
on a mass scale is not realistic here and
yet, leaving the wrongs unaddressed seems
not quite right either. We need a procedure
for atonement that is both real and functions
outside of the judicial system. Here, as in
so many areas, we can be inspired by the example
of religion, and in particular Judaism. It
has been the particular insight of Judaism
to focus on hurt: how easy it is to feel it,
how hard it is to express it and how awkward
but also necessary it is to make amends for
perpetrating it. We find the religion’s
response in what is known as the Day of Atonement,
one of the most psychologically effective
mechanisms ever devised for the resolution
of social conflict. Falling on the tenth day
of Tishrei, shortly after the beginning of
the Jewish new year, the Day of Atonement
(or Yom Kippur) is a solemn and critical event
in the Hebrew Calendar. Leviticus instructs
that on this date, Jews must set aside their
usual family and commercial activities and
mentally review their actions over the preceding
year, identifying all those whom they have
caused pain to or behaved unjustly towards.
Together in synagogue, they must repeat in
prayer:
We have sinned, we have acted treacherously,
We have robbed, we have spoken slander.
We have acted perversely, we have acted wickedly,
We have acted presumptuously, we have been
violent, we have framed lies. They must then
seek out those whom they have frustrated,
angered, discarded casually or otherwise betrayed
and offer them their fullest contrition. This
is God’s will as is the requirement for
forgiveness, so long as the apology is real.
‘All the people are in fault’, says the
evening prayer, and so ‘may all the people
of Israel be forgiven, including all the strangers
who live in their midst.’ On the Day of
Atonement, Jews are advised to contact their
colleagues, sit down with their parents and
children and send letters to acquaintances,
lovers and ex-friends overseas, and to catalogue
their relevant moments of temper, infidelity,
cowardice and greed. In turn, those to whom
they apologise are urged to recognise the
sincerity and effort which the offender has
invested in asking for their forgiveness.
Rather than let annoyance and bitterness towards
their petitioner well up in them once more,
they must be ready to draw a line under past
incidents, aware that their own lives have
surely also not been free of fault. God enjoys
a privileged role in this cycle of apology:
he is the only perfect being and therefore
the only one to whom the need to apologise
is alien. As for everyone else, imperfection
is embedded in human nature, and therefore
so too must be the will to contrition.
The prescriptions of the Day of Atonement
bring comfort to both parties to an injury:
as victims of hurt, we frequently don’t
bring up what ails us, because so many wounds
look absurd, small or strange in the light
of day. Our vulnerability insults our self-conception;
we are in pain and at the same time offended
that we could so easily be so. Alternatively,
when we are the ones who have caused someone
else pain, and yet failed to offer apology,
it was perhaps because acting badly made us
feel intolerably guilty. We can be so sorry
that we find ourselves incapable of saying
sorry. We run away from our victims and act
with strange rudenness towards them, not because
we aren’t bothered by what we did, but because
what we did makes us feel uncomfortable with
an unmanageable intensity. Our victims hence
have to suffer not only the original hurt,
but also the subsequent coldness we display
towards them on account of our tormented consciences.
All this a Day of Atonement helps to correct.
A period in which human error is proclaimed
as a general truth makes it easier to confess
to specific infractions. It is more bearable
to own up to our follies when the highest
authority has told us that we are all childishly
yet ultimately forgiveably demented to begin
with. The secular world needs to learn from
the Day of Atonement. Functioning without
a culture of atonement implies that we are
perfect, or that our imperfections are only
things that a court of law can handle or that
no one can be forgiven if they are sorry.
In fact, we are of course deeply imperfect,
courts can’t handle every occasion of nastiness
and we can’t ever progress and live together
in society if we can’t regularly offer and
accept an apology. We need to learn, from
the best sides of religion, how regularly
to confess to foolishness and forgive it in
ourselves
and others.
We hope you enjoyed this film.
If you want to learn more about Friendship explore our range of books, games and gifts all about Friendship on your screen now.